attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
bien je vous présente patrick qui va
animer cet atelier de team building
bonjour à tous patrick moi là bas je
suis comédien j'ai joué dans commissaire
moulin dans ce but la brocante et depuis
je suis au chômage allait s'y attendre
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'anime
des ateliers à la con dans les
entreprises de merde noire tout à fait
patrick tame patron on n'a pas d'argent
pour les augmentations et on a les
moyens de se payer un coach et coutumes
un anneau mais moi ça m'a rien coûté et
j'ai pris ça sur le budget du comité
d'entreprise
c'est pour ça qu'on a plus de places de
cinéma tout à fait allez moi je m'en
voulais de solidaires avec vous je vous
laisse avec l'intermittente aller pour
commencer cette belle journée nous
allons faire l'exercice des animaux
totems alors tom moi je t'observe depuis
un petit moment et je vois bien un félin
un tigre dans un chat un chat inoffensif
un chat d'appartement un chaton petit
rebelle mois un papillon non nadine faut
que ce soit un gain annuel de 3 semble
suffire à la tâche
une bonne grosse norland et moi je vais
faire la ddt rapport au chiffre haut et
toi sylvain tu feras le blaireau non le
héros par marc je m'en fous de l'animal
le blaireau saatchi bronze allez on
enchaîne tout de suite avec l'exercice
du flamant rose qui consiste à me
regarder dans les yeux tout en touchant
le bout de son nez avec son doigt et en
maintenant la jambe en l'air
non mon à l'air de coin là oui mais vous
avez l'air de conte tous ensemble et
c'est ça le principe du team building
en fait c'est un exercice quand vous
n'avez pas d'idée d'exercice absolument
je me suis fait griller allez on
enchaîne tout de suite avec l'exercice
de la confiance on va se laisser tomber
en arrière on est en confiance en son
partenaire pour qu'ils nous rattrape
allez le blaireau tu commences tu va
rattraper le chaton ballon je vais
rattraper la vache moi comme ça au
passage pourrait toucher les molles et
pour finir vous allez vous allongé au
sol et vous aller méditer pendant 30
minutes
ah ça c'est vachement bien ça permet de
se recentrer sur soi ah non pas du tout
non c'est juste que j'en ai ras le cul
de vous entendre moi ça me permet de
tirer jusqu'à 18h30 ses proches me casse
sinon moi j'ai une idée des exercices on
se met tous autour d'une table on ce
soit avec un cube il coupait le lieu
s'appelle l'apéro bolides et le blaireau
[Musique]